now building that wall
across our southern border wasn't just a
signature trump campaign
promise it was a signal to americans all
over the country who'd suffered the ill
effects
of illegal immigration but now the
incoming biden administration is telling
those same americans they're going to
basically be on your own
their own and my next guest is an angel
mom who does not want to see the wall
canceled joining me now is maureen
maloney her son matthew was killed by an
illegal
immigrant 10 years ago maureen
president incoming president biden also
wants to
give amnesty to 11 million illegals
and end deportations i guess for
everyone for 100 days who the heck
cares about covet uh what message does
that send
uh to law-abiding americans and legal
immigrants across the country
you know it's a slap in the face to
law-abiding americans you know we're a
country of rules and laws
and laws have to be abided by and so by
giving amnesty to
these illegal aliens which you know you
said 11 million but we really don't know
it's probably
closer to 20 million of them here in the
country
you're rewarding them for breaking our
laws and you're sending the message
to other foreigners that our borders are
open and if you come here we will reward
you
for breaking our laws now it's really
shocking is it not that maureen um
you have thousands upon thousands
of hondurans and others from central
america and elsewhere
who know that joe biden's going to give
them all these benefits and congress
will probably
you know give them free health care and
obviously their kids already get public
education
and snap benefits and so forth but it's
amazing how word
carries pretty fast right so the
caravans start and police are
overwhelmed and
yet we have this amazing fortification
around
the capitol uh building and all of
washington's lockdown but
apparently no appetite to actually you
know protect the rest of the country
and and after the inauguration they
should take
all those national guardsmen and put
them down on the southern border and
protect
the americans no i wouldn't hold your
breath
on that but here's what biden's dhs
nominee
said about the migrant caravan i think
there are a number of them now heading
to our southern border
when people present themselves at our
border we apply
the laws of our nation to determine
whether they qualify for relief
under our humanitarian laws or whether
they don't
well maureen we've seen how this worked
and practiced during past
administrations and early on in this
administration
they let everyone in right and then they
give them
a court date a couple years down the
road to show up
it's catch and release they release them
into the country
they move further into the interior and
they never show up for their court date
all right maureen we got to go but thank
you so much for joining us
and your story is unbelievable